you guys
it's like we're in high school and we're
at the cool table
right yeah
and were you a cheerleader no she was
talking a little miss artsy fartsy in
high school yeah she wore the turtleneck
and everything that's hilarious
that's hilarious
where'd you go to school bishop o'hara
hislop who cares
we played you
you you really look familiar did you uh
you cheered for them didn't you
no
yes i did
a w e
s o m e awesome awesome is what we are
we're the football superstars a w
remember that we crushed you like 42 10.
luke is going to use his laser pointer
to point to account setup you click on
that first then a whole new knot no no
no luke come on come on not on oscar's
head
all right luke come on stop it what i'm
stopping it that's what you said give me
the pointer so you just want me to move
it that's you're being totally unclear
here i'm just gonna go ahead and move it
no just power it down no no no no no not
on angela's poop come on come on luke
seriously all right fine fine i'll just
go okay i'm going all right
okay
good job
okay email accounts so we're starting
with account setup oh my god is it in my
eyeball
yeah i think he's burning my eye michael
do something shack up you have to stop
this luke can i have that no okay i am
going to count down from five
five
four
i'm not kidding
three
two
one give me
okay are going to learn to be more
professional luke
that's what you're going to do luke
what the hell was that i had to do that
scroll it all right are we good
you're okay
he's okay
i've seen this kid before he's one of
the kids that sneaks onto my farm and
steals my hemp yeah i know that guy he's
that farmer that goes really crappy weed
you ready to give me my discount no
no okay what have you been doing in here
this whole time what kind of business is
this we're a paper company the best
paper company in the whole wide world
right do i knock it off
you'd better think about what you were
doing young man you better think about
what you're doing no i'm an adult i
don't have to think or do anything
you're a kid you're a little snot-nosed
punk kid who thinks he's better than
everybody else
because he's some hot shot and you don't
know anything about sales
so stop being a disrespectful little
jerk okay sales
yes sales you sell pizza last time i
checked that's called sales you're such
a loser what did you just call him a
loser what did you say a loser what i
wasn't okay with that water stop
say it you just made this worse a whole
lot worse i can make him talk michael
freeze i'm in do you want to go over the
rules one more time no no new new
i'm looking in my wallet for money so
you can tell me my fortune
i promise it's worth it oh i can see you
walking out of here and you're thrilled
with your reading
what are you
michael what did you tell him
nothing then why are his hands up
bill
he told me he couldn't show it to me but
he has a gun
okay let's call it a day
nice job be good
that's good
good work everybody
so you've just been bought by
probably a lot of questions
hi i'm christian slater what's it like
to work for sabre
let's find out together
working at sabre means taking on the
challenge of the road that rises to meet
you
savor respecting the past
but opening the window to the future
have you ever tasted a rainbow
and savor
you will
you'll find it easy to embrace the saber
spirit
welcome
we're very excited to go on this journey
with you
so you've been shown a nonsensical video
you're probably wondering what's going
on
well you're not alone
years ago
the senator promised a left turn lane by
the arby's
so i want to know where in the name of
horsey sauce is it
well yeah you hold on hi
i keep seeing this symbol in the
accounts from last year it's it's all
over the place i don't know what it
means that's the reason kevin got fired
it's his magic number he used to use it
to balance his accounts
he used to call that a colevin he told
a mistake plus cleveland gets you home
by seven
he was home by 4 45 that day
yeah yeah
okay
uh
something like
[Music]
it's not that i want you
not to say but
[Music]
is all you have to do to make it real
is anyone filming this seriously
aaron it's either taping or calling
what would you
do
if my heart was turning into
you know what walter jr is here
why don't you come up and join us yeah
oh come up and do something with me i'm
just having a good time getting to know
andy's friends here get up there and
sing or i will cut your larynx and
you'll never be able to sing again whoa
come
this on thing man i don't even
may the good lord be with you down every
road you wrong
and may sunshine and happiness surround
you when you're far from home
[Music]
and may you grow to be proud
dignified and true
and do unto others as you'd have
[Music]
cheers cheers get your own guitar
morning dwight
who are you
who am i
i'm jim we've been working together for
12 years
we're joked white
you're not jim jim's not asian
you seriously never noticed hey hats off
to you for not seeing race
all right then jim uh why don't you tell
me about that sale that you made
yesterday
uh wellington systems sold them 10 cases
of 24-pound letter stock or were you
talking about creek or murphy because i
didn't close that one yet but i'm hoping
i've got a voicemail from paul krieger
waiting for me
please enter your password
you have one new message
no no no no that is sensitive
information only for employees not
outsiders dwight cut it out i'm trying
to work you don't work here you're not
jim jim i got us that dinner reservation
greek goes 7 30. oh great can't wait
jim's at the dentist this morning and
steve is an actor friend of ours i don't
know who you are
but you are not jim
this is jim
hmm
you